[Music]
the annual military parade to celebrate
the founding of north korea is a
time-honored tradition
but this one showed that even the hermit
kingdom has had to adapt to the covet
era
goose stepping in ppe their cried the
leader of live long
muffled by their masks
and there the leader was looking rather
different
his obesity had long been the subject of
discussion
but this was a new look slim kim
perhaps his weight loss was like boris
johnson's response to the fact that
obesity increases the risk of severe
illness from covert 19. but there are no
certainties in analyzing the situation
in north korea
officially and remarkably the country
has recorded zero covert cases it sealed
its border early on and has kept it shut
nor did it send a team to the tokyo
olympics
and this month it also rejected the
offer of nearly three million
chinese-made coveted vaccines asking
that they'd be redirected to media
countries
there are still very low numbers of
testing that has been done in throughout
the country
um but there have not been the signs of
massive panic
of massive precautions or massive
measures being taken that you would
normally see if there was an outbreak
that they were trying to
conceal
the march was also a signal that
whatever the truth of covet 19 in north
korea the country is back to business as
usual
there was warning of that last month
when the un said that the regime had
restarted its nuclear reactor
potentially producing plutonium for
warheads
even sealed off from it north korea
still has the potential to cause serious
trouble for the rest of the world
tom cheshire sky news shanghai